the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video
all right my friends it looks like we
now have some new information regarding
house of the dragon
as you all know hbo is developing a show
based on george rr martin's fire and
blood vol
1. the new series will focus on house
targaryen's downfall
during all of the events surrounding the
dance of dragons
now hbo's website still says this
happened 300 years before the events in
game of thrones but as i have said
before it actually happened about 170
years before the main series
if you have seen any of my recent videos
then you would know they have been
filming different scenes for several
weeks now
we have already seen a lot of the main
characters on set during the filming of
the first season
well it looks like fans have spotted a
new actor who will be in house of the
dragon
now before i go any further i do want to
give a spoiler warning let me show you
who has been added to the cast of house
of the dragon
veteran actor graham mctavish known for
his role as an outlander
and the hobbit will be making an
appearance in the first season
about a week ago graham did reveal that
he was in cornwall england
this is interesting because that's where
health of the dragon has been filming
for several weeks
if you look at the set photo that does
look like it's him now what fans really
want to know is which character will he
be
one theory is that he's sir harold
westerling the lord commander of the
kingsguard for king viserys targaryen
sir harold is eventually replaced as
lord commander by sir kristin cole
now an even better theory is graham will
be lionel strong
the lord of harrenhal lionel strong
serves as both the master of laws
and hand of the king to king viserys his
son
harwinstrong aka breakbones eventually
gets involved with king viserys's
daughter rhaenyra targaryen
either way this character will be
heavily involved with the main story
given that he's so close to the king
this is a face we will see again and
again
now i will be honest i'm not very
familiar with the actor's work but as
i've said before i'm very confident hbo
will find great actors and actresses
i say that because they did such an
amazing job with game of thrones
and as a matter of fact they get great
actors for almost all of their shows so
i'm not worried about that
now what i really want to show you is a
different photo that i find very
interesting
i haven't been able to show you this yet
but if you haven't seen it already this
should get you very excited for the
things to come
this photo right here might be our first
glimpse at one of the actors interacting
with one of the dragons
for those of you that don't know this
show will have an incredible amount of
dragons
which is why house of the dragon is such
a fitting name
now it's really hard to know how
accurate this adaptation will be
based on what happened with game of
thrones they may not adapt everything
directly from the books the way it was
written
we just don't know but if you have seen
the little mini documentary
hbo released a few years ago about the
dance of dragons
we might have an idea of just how many
dragons we will see
king viserys targaryen the first of his
name was lucky enough to ride balerion
the black dread
the same dragon that was once aegon the
conquerors
this is arguably the biggest dragon
westeros has ever seen
unfortunately we may not see this dragon
in house of the dragon
because belarion does die before the
dance he will not be involved in any of
the fighting in the later seasons
however there are over a dozen other
dragons we should see
now although we may never see valeria on
the black dread we will essentially see
the next best thing
the dragon known as veigar once ridden
by aegon the conqueror's sister wife
visenya
this is one of the very few dragons that
came directly from valyria
after visenya dies there are a few other
characters who ride the dragon but the
character who we will most likely see
riding this dragon the most is
among one eye the son of king viserys
targaryen
in alicent hightower now because the
dragon will be green screened we won't
actually see it in any of the set photos
but that might be what we're looking at
in the photo
this is only speculation but that might
be aemond one eye
and his ferocious dragon veigar now it
almost looks like he could be riding the
dragon
the way his body is angled he is also
looking up at something but he could
just be greeting the dragon before he
rides it
some of you might not know this but by
the time of the dance of dragons
vegar was a hardened survivor of a
hundred battles
he had grown almost as large as belarion
and was the oldest
and largest of the dragons in westeros
it's said that no living dragon could
match her size or ferocity
now i want to go over the other dragons
we should see in house of the dragon
aim on one eye's brother had his own
dragon as well
after king viserys targaryen dies his
other son aegon targaryen the second of
his name
becomes the new king this is obviously
one of the things that leads to the
dance of dragons
the new king aegon had a dragon named
sunfire and according to archmaester
gildane
sunfire was the most beautiful dragon
ever seen upon the earth
sunfire had gleaming gold scales which
shone like beaten gold in the sunlight
we should also see this dragon kill one
of the main characters in this series
but i won't spoil that now
this king aegon targaryen the second of
his name had a sister wife as well
her name was helena targaryen and she
wrote the dragon name
dream fire it said that dream fire was a
slender she dragon
who dies during the dance of dragons
like almost all of the other dragons i
will name here
king viserys targaryen and his wife
alison hightower had another son
who was their youngest daron targaryen
and his dragon was tessarion
another one of the she dragons so we
have veigar
sunfire dreamfire and tesarion who will
be fighting on the side of the greens
which is allison hightower and her son
king aegon targaryen the second of his
name
now let me go over the dragons who are
on the side of the blacks
because they have a hell of a lot more
rhaenara targaryen who was king viserys
targaryen's daughter
in air rode the dragon cyrax another she
dragon who got her name from a valyrian
goddess
raynera's uncle and lover daemon rode
the dragon known as karaxis
this dragon gets an arguably the
greatest dragon battle during the dance
of dragons over the lake of the gods eye
a scene i am dying to see rhaenyra
targaryen had a lot of suns
and they had a lot of dragons her
firstborn son
jacary's velaryon was a dragon rider
whose dragon was vermax
her second born son lou carey's velaryon
was also a dragon rider whose dragon was
arax
her third born son joffrey velaryon was
a dragon rider as well
whose dragon was named tyraxes now there
are several other dragons around during
this era who i won't name here
because they either die before anyone
rides them in the riots of king's
landing
or they die shortly after their first
ride i just want to stick to the ones we
will most likely see in a battle
or at least in more than one scene lady
bayla targaryen
daughter of daemon targaryen was a
dragon rider whose dragon was named
moondancer her dragon is eventually
killed by sunfire
the dragon of king aegon targaryen the
second of his name
rhaenys targaryen who is the wife of
lord corliss valerion was also a dragon
rider
whose dragon was named melees rhaenys
and her dragon gets in arguably the
second greatest dragon battle during the
dance of dragons
unfortunately they both die during that
fight
another scene i cannot wait to see now
although rhaenyra and a lot of her
children already had dragons of their
own
they have even more dragons just sitting
around on dragonstone waiting for new
riders
sheepsteeler is one of those dragons we
should see who is written by a character
known as nettles
someone who will have a romantic
relationship with daemon
nettles and her dragon disappear right
before the dance of dragons is over
another one of these dragons is named
vermathor
once belonging to king jiharis targaryen
he will be ridden by hugh hammer during
the dance of dragons
and another one of the dragons left to
go wild on dragonstone was sea
smoke who once belonged to lehnor
velaryon
we will see a character known as adam of
hall ride this dragon during the dance
also don't forget there are even more
dragons i did not mention here because
they aren't really involved in any of
the fighting
although they are around in king's
landing now that we are beginning to see
actors interacting with dragons on this
set i just wanted to give a brief
description of the dragons from this era
we will be meeting all of them soon
enough let me know what you think of
this photo down below
what character do you think this is and
what dragon do you think they will
be riding i'm interested in hearing what
you have to say
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by to watch my video
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
you